on s'initie à la relaxation au collège
anatole-france des clayes-sous-bois 10 à
15 minutes d'ateliers pour une classe de
5e le bien-être à l'école pour lutter
contre le décrochage
on essaye de les initier à la relaxation
et ensuite on renforce les compétences
psychosociales notamment les compétences
savoir gérer son stress et émotion avoir
des relations apaisées gérer ces
conflits
quitte à petit on voit alors ça que
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut faire
régulièrement mais du coup c'est vrai
que mais il a plus plus vont apprendre à
apprendre de la distance à respirer
calmement et plus effectivement le payer
moins en moins de conflits série ça aide
leur expérience est l'une de celles
mises en valeur par l'académie de
versailles
chaque année environ 15 mille jeunes
arrêtent l'école
c'est un chiffre qui bouge à peu près
tous les deux jours pour la raison
simple que c'est extrêmement difficile à
compter les décrocheurs
donc on est sûr effectivement un ordre
de grandeur
plus qu'un chiffre n'est l'ordre de
grandeur est le bon puisque la vraie
donnée c'est le nombre de jeunes qui
quittent le système scolaire sans
qualification
ceux là on les connaît et effectivement
on peut les qualifier de décrocheurs
reprise d'études activités manuelles ou
encore travail sur l'estimé de soi 500
décrocheurs sont repérés dans les
yvelines chaque année